عند السفر ، فإن أحد أكبر
التحديات التي يمكن أن نواجهها هو التحدث
وفهم لغة جديدة
في كوميديا الخيال العلمي لدوغلاس آدم ، دل
ل المسافر إلى المجرة ، ا
تكر مخلوقًا غريبًا لحل هذ
المشكلة ، ت
تقديمه لأول مرة في تعديل بي بي سي لل
تاب  من المحتمل أن تكون سمكة بابل هي أغرب
شيء في الكون ،
إذا قمت بلصق واحدة في أذنك ،
فستفهم على الفور
أي شيء يتم إرساله إليك بأي شكل من أشكال
اللغة
الآن ، هذا ليس سمكة صغيرة ولكنه يطمح
لأداء العديد من الوظائف نفسها التي
تترجم اليابانية إلى عدة لغات
مختلفة  لغات وسأعطيها فرصة
[موسيقى] ،
لدي الآن قناع البحر فوق
قناع وجهي المعتاد ،
اضغط على هذا الزر ، والآن أنا متصل عبر
البلوتوث بالهاتف الذكي مع
تطبيق cmask
جاهز للترجمة ، فلنمنحه  اذهب إلى
أين توجد
محطة القطار ومحطة القطار ليس تمامًا ما كنت
أحاول قوله
أين محطة القطار نعم
وهذا ما يبدو عليه في اليابانية ، لقد
حصلت على ما يرام تقريبًا هناك  حسنًا ، حاول الزوجان
ولكن هل أحتاج حقًا إلى القيام بذلك
بمجرد إزالة القناع
الذي اتصلت به مع الرئيس التنفيذي للشركة اليابانية
التي
صنعته وسألته عن سبب إنشائه ،
فكرت في أفضل طريقة يمكننا المساهمة بها
في عالم اليوم  تقنية الروبوت
التي لدينا الآن من
خلال إعادة تعريف القناع ، فهي لا تساعد فقط على
صحتك ولكن أيضًا في رقمنة الأصوات
والنصوص دون استخدام يديك ،
أردت تسهيل
التواصل عند ارتداء الأقنعة باستخدام
تقنية اخترعتها أنت وفريقك.
استجابة مباشرة
لوباء kova 19 ،
نعم ، أجبر الوباء الناس في
العالم على ارتداء أقنعة طوال الوقت ،
كنت أرغب في حل المضايقات
التي تسببها الحياة باستخدام الأقنعة ،
وأتطلع إلى اليوم الذي يمكنني فيه
استخدام قناع مثل هذا وإجراء مقابلة معك  في
الوقت الفعلي
ويمكنك فهم لغتي الإنجليزية ويمكنني
أن أفهم لغتك اليابانية